Hey Christian.
>> Hey Chelsea.
>> Your box is done.
>> Yeah.
>> What's going on here?
>> Well I, I've gotten some feedback and I was just wondering.
>> Yeah?
>> You want to try it?
>> Oh, sure. Wow. Where do I start? Okay.
>> You tell me.
>> Well, the first thing that stands out is
this guy here. And I immediately want to lift
it. Okay. I'm turning this around. Oh gosh, this
looks dangerous, but I still want to touch it.
kind of turning this around here. There's some text here. It looks like it's
telling a bit of a story. There was a little pig, he was
chasing a wolf. It makes me kind of want to turn the box, here. Oh,
and sparkles. Who doesn't love sparkles? Of course I want to touch this. Hmm.
>> Lots going on.
>> Yeah. And as we saw, people did various things with it.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Well, there was a few things that I did intentionally here. One is,
that I made these finger holes. Just the
right size, and you'd grab it, like a bowling
ball. Well that's, human size. And here, it's
a little tempting to kind of touch it. And
maybe somebody would, want to, flitter with those. And
the balls kind of feel nice and well somewhere, here's
the squishy thing that you play with and you can even pick the box up from that,
and there's a tail. So why do we grab this? It's got an affordance for,
for grabbing. And there's one more thing. I'm using the power of story
here, because it says once upon, and you turn it. Once upon a time, there was a
little pig, who was chasing a wolf down a rabbit hole. Yeah.
>> [SOUND]
>> There's my box.